このじゃあ女子今日はこちら版ジェムズというもの買ってみましたねこれ結構面白そう
で小正に書いてある通りで僕でも楽しめるみたいで救っずボールを組み合わせで
いろんなものを作れるというやつで会えるとか蛇さんと3
たこさんくま版 ohana さんという感じなくくっつけたまでいろんなものを作る
みたいですこれじゃあ400入ってると作って作り直して無限の可能性ということで
ブロックのもっとこう年間いろんなことができるバージョンっていうわけですごいを
選んで魅力的だと思って買ってしまいました
2芸もイラストを見る限り今回子供たちがすごく楽しそうにしてますねあげてみ
ましょう
ああああああ
出ましたすごいもうくっつくんだけど結構でこうゆうざ組み合わせる系列で面白いけど
無限ですから可能性がこれで何からいろいろ作れるらしいです説明書ですねなんか
いろんなのが作れるよっていうのが書いてあります凄いねこれはすごいと2つ後屈切る
とお揃いで買っちゃうって言うところたくさん決め合わせると思うで分限ですはこう
いう感じでどんどんくっつけ
いけるということでございますため性なんか作ってみましょう
よしできました
[音楽]
要求そこらへんになりぞをそこらへんにあるお花で作っ2って本当にこういう事でも
組み合わせ自由でも何でも作れるというのがこちらのなんでチュッパチャップス団地目
ですねこれマジで楽しいですが俺だけ子供やってて首相はネーズって言ったけど月から
多分楽しい安保に ameba まじか浜田奴は私たち完成してもらいました
[音楽]
これは
ブーバー今ヌー
にこれはキモいちょいでぽろぽろ落ちるとです
気持ちいいなちょっと作っ追加してきもってくらいだなそこそこ重いです開いてあげて
今回はこちらのパンジェームズ3600を使って何ができるのか
もう全然にちょっと普通に遊びますデリカこういうことだっていることに分けましょう
えっ
すけどね阿部も持っているこれあるな数がだいぶ気も面白いすっ
[音楽]
すわー
選手が色分けすればよかったん
ヤキモチますできます
立っ
[音楽]
疲れちゃうこれ
よしはい定義で武人全部の色分けがさん漁師町もう3600を感じる頭があるととも
いろんなことができると思うんでやめちゃいまー著者してるともうちょっとまず
ちょっと何でも作ってみよ
[音楽]
ん
んできました臭いが酷いがフレシア
パットに腐ったヒトデマンだな次こちら
ジャジャン腐りかけの花君です
ああああああ
ていた
これは犬ですねまったくもって犬です犬なんですけど光やばとってねちょっとこの検索
から光が漏れているという状態ではない小さなボウルで出来るんですけどもこのた
語り合っても経つというわけでとても優れておりますね
me
犬ですよこれクローバーで結構いけると思うんだよね暗黒ブース暗黒物質みたいとして
ねちょっと黒で何か作ってみましょう
アイテムで完成しました深すぎるとと鮭が安いのでこれがいなさいと言うけれどと思い
ますサントラチャリティーこれ[ __ ]2016夏でクリームバーて fx で座りとね
あのパットに見たら完全に熊野しか見えないよねこれはちょっと我が家のトイレに
仕掛けて安全ずで果たして蜘蛛は再現できるのかちょっと実験してみると思います
[音楽]
ん
war
[音楽]
しています